Should the biotoxin binder be taken with food or not?
You know, some of your nutrition, I'll be honest with you, I'm not very good at trying to separate out with my personal supplements with food or not.
I'm not very good at taking my personal supplements because I get so busy I forget.
So, so that's not a good thing to admit to all your people, but you guys, some of you are really good at taking your things.
And I don't typically, you know, accept what it's really important to all people to take things with food or without food unless it's really important.
A lot of your nutrition are food products are saying they're a whole food in nature. So, taking them with food really doesn't make any difference and it can actually be better.
Some things taken with food can help with your stomach and even things that maybe should be taken on an empty stomach.
For a lot of people that are really ill, it hurts their stomach and they get an empty stomach. So, taking it with their food can help with stomach upset.
And, you know, if their stomach gets upset when they take their stuff on an empty stomach, they just won't take it.
The binders probably better taken away from food. So, I would say if you're really good at it, I would take the bio toxin binder away from food.
Some things like I tell you, if you're, if I have you on a digestive enzyme for food, you take it with your meal, you certainly take HCl with a meal, not an empty stomach.
And, some things like I have you on an enzyme therapy, I say you have to take this at an empty stomach.
It's just a must now. Go from an instance.